So my question to you is a social
contract or a legal system replaced
religion as moral framework and a way we
are?
I think it's because it's because of the
gap between what we articulated and what
we don't know.
Something has to fill that gap.
Like I think the law could be,
could,
could replace it if the law was total,
but it isn't.
It's bounded and the incorrect and
there's something in risks.
It has to rest on something inside
that's like this mediator between what
we articulate,
what we don't understand.
It's something like customer,
something like expectation.
It's something like the intrinsic sense
of justice,
you know that the law itself is aiming
at and those aren't fully articulated,
but without them there'd be no
grounding.
Like without the body,
the law would be a dictionary,
you know?
And if you don't know what a word means,
using the dictionary is helpful,
but not that helpful because like unless
you've had the experience of anger,
the dictionary,
I can't tell you what anger means,
it's just refers to other words,
but the words themselves refer to
something else and the law refers to
something else.
And without that it has to be in tune
with that something else.
It has to be in accordance with it.
And so I don't think we can ever
delineate the proper body of laws.
And that's also why you like ideological
utopias.
See the ideological utopia is dispensed
with the transcendent.
They say,
this is what we need to do.
It's like,
no,
you don't.
No,
that's not good.
You have to leave space for what you
kind of know and for what you don't
know.
And I mean,
you know,
in the story of the Tower of Babel,
human beings make this massive building.
It's supposed to reach up to the heavens
so that it'll take the place of God.
Well,
that's,
that's the earliest warning we have of
the danger of making things so big that
you confuse them with God and God gets
irritated and comes down and makes
everybody speak different languages and
scatters them.
It's like,
well,
that's what happens when you try to make
something a totality is that it starts
to fragment inside and disintegrates
into catastrophe and so it's,
it's almost as if we have to maintain
this articulated space inside the dream,
inside the custom,
something like that,
because otherwise it doesn't work.
And I think that's the same as having
respect for the fact that we have
bodies.
You know,
we're not just abstract creatures that
follow rules.
We're not that at all.
We only follow certain rules.
We won't follow the other ones and our
societies will crumble.
And so,
and we just don't know enough to
articulate the entire landscape of
behavior with articulated rules.
Not at all.
We can't do it.
It's beyond us.
Yep.